hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge von
freddy ich habe einfach mal auf conti
nach zwei gedrückt das telefon klingelt
natürlich mal wieder und wir
hier ganz normalen website nacht können
wieder schauen ob da ein schon einmal
ist es ist ja nicht so dass ich gerade
erst angefangen hat ist in fünf und in
kempen fahren die beiden noch drei
warten einfach mal ab ob ich kann ihn
kaum noch unten tempels ausgefallen
alles ist irgendwie ausgefallen da ist
nichts mehr ändern fünf sondern jetzt
direkt vor meiner tür das video geht
minute ausgefallen zwei sind in 1a und
der andere ist wo zum teufel ist er
jetzt zwischenstand 2 sind weg dahin ist
auf jeden fall einer im gang ich will
auch dani dieses dings weg weil es dann
immer angst habe dass sie irgendwo einer
stehen
1/10 dining area hier ist noch einer in
show stage und der andere ist ist dass
da einer das sind dann immer diese
momente wo ich mir denke nein ich finde
sich die kämpfe gehen
noch immer in der show stage einander
dining area und fein
der west hall ich muss noch fünf stunden
überleben und habe nur die hälfte an akt
ist einfach nur der bildschirm weg
gegangen ich habe mich erschrocken
mithin keine ahnung was ich weiß nicht
wie ich als zuschauer ist ob das
überhaupt gegen was ich höre geräusche
sind jetzt für euch ansatzweise gruselig
ist aber für mich selber hier gerade
mitten in der nacht das ganze
aufzunehmen ist das schon
bitte bleibt da einfach 12
ist aber weiter
ich werde nie was tun
in einer mannschaft er ist bäcker haben
einen der westfalen in der show stage
und einen
word of the car show stage einer
gastrolle
schaut mal schaut mich an ich zu
internet verknüpft also eine chance
pages keiner dann in der gastrolle noch
immer
dritter ist der dritte und ich will das
nicht schon wieder was ausgefallen
alles ausgefallen meine freizeit youtube
könnt könnt ihr bitte mir klicks klicks
geben ohne dass ich das spiel spielen
das ist wirklich mein lieblingscharakter
weil der jet die ganze schöne der show
stage macht nicht wie die anderen sind
wo ist er denn jetzt schon wieder hin
wir haben noch immer eine der rollstuhl
einer der shows age und der dritte du
heilige kaká erschreckt mich noch nicht
so klein ist fettes entleihen er steht
in vier ar steht in zwei er steht nicht
mehr in 28 die tür ist jetzt zu dies
auch nie so viel energie darf ich nicht
verbrauchen das fand ich denke mir
vereinbaren muss gleich 600 kilometer
fahren auto und ich schwitze schon
wieder wie übrigens kaufmann merger von
visa ich kann es nicht mehr lange machen
bis korrekt du bleibt zumindest da
hinten
wir haben einen in 1b einen 1a und einen
direkt vor meiner fresse ich hab's 6
prozent ab
nicht jedoch aus verdammte scheiße für
prozent
auf der politik
an dieser stelle diese klatsche werden
immer lauter an euch das video gefallen
hat ich denke zunächst mit einer
bewertung ich mag das spiel eigentlich
weil ich das spiel kann ich innerhalb
von zehn minuten so zum schwitzen
bringen wie vier stunden sport und dann
sehen wir uns vielleicht in der woche
oder so im nächsten part wieder und dann
versuche ich mal nach zwei zu schaffen
und es gibt ja noch fünf andere oder
vier an oder sekt oder drei andere teile
da die werde ich auch noch machen was
kannst du eigentlich